in front of his own king in front of the
black king james gives a check is there
a is there a b4 move here yeah this is
another
sacrifice i've seen jordan play this
before uh this exact position with the
white pieces i remember looking at this
move which the computer actually
approved of
um at a deeper level and it's it's a
very interesting idea because we're
trying to open up the position and this
is really exciting already right there's
this this move but ivanka
you must know more about this than me
yeah i'm trying to record my theory
actually because there's two times that
you can actually play this poor move and
one of times you grab the pawn the other
time you actually reject it you just
slide the queen and to challenge its
counterpart
and i'm checking the database and the
main move here is actually for black not
to get greedy and just step the queen
backwards and offer herself up for a
trade yeah already yeah just to show the
idea this pawn is loose it's actually up
for grabs you can take it but after
white blocks with the knight you have a
problem for black suddenly all of your
pieces are still asleep still at home
not